All right.
Let's just remind ourselves for
a moment where we were,
and that is that we were
talking about the structure of
the atom.
And we talked about how
classical physics,
the classical mechanics,
classical electromagnetism
failed to explain how the
electron and the nucleus hung
together.
And I said that the clues about
how to solve that conundrum
actually came from a different
area of discussion,
and that is this wave-particle
duality.
And so remember that I said we
are going to put aside that
discussion of the structure of
the atom all the way until next
Monday.
Pardon?
No class Monday?
We're going to put it aside all
the way until next Wednesday.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER] You sound surprised?
You're not.
It's a student holiday on
Monday.
And we're going to talk about
the wave-particle duality of
light and matter,
get clues from that area of
discussion, and we're going to
apply those clues,
then, to solving the structure
of the atom next Wednesday.
Now, we started on this
discussion by talking about the
wave-like nature of radiation.
And to illustrate that,
we did this two-slit experiment
where we saw an interference
pattern.
And we talked about how that
interference pattern arose
because of the property of
superposition of waves.
That is, if you have waves in
the two same points in space,
their amplitudes superpose,
or they add.
And because some of those
amplitudes are positive and some
are negative,
depending on the relative phase
of the waves,
you have constructive or you
have destructive interference.
And specifically what we were
trying to understand is,
in the two-slit experiment,
why we had this line of bright
spots, dark spots,
bright spots,
dark spots.
And we analyzed it by drawing
these semicircles,
which represent the wave front
kind of sneaking through this
little pinhole here,
this slit, emanating equally in
all directions.
These semicircles here
represent the crest of the wave.
The distance here between these
crests is 1 lambda,
is one wavelength.
And when we look closely-- Can
we dim the lights in the front
here?
If you closely,
what we discovered is that all
points along this line
constructively interfere.
That is we have waves that are
at the same place in space and
the maxima and the minima are in
the same place in space,
and so that's going to lead to
a very bright spot here on the
screen.
The amplitude is going to be
twice as high as it was in each
of the individual waves.
And we get this very bright
spot.
And we realize that along this
line, the difference in the
distance traveled by the two
waves that are constructively
interfering was 1 lambda.
And then we did so for this
line here.
And we discovered that all
along this line,
we had these two waves in
phase.
All along this line we had
constructive interference which,
of course, imaged as another
bright spot.
And when we analyzed it,
we found that the difference in
the distance traveled by the two
waves was 2 lambda.
And likewise here.
All along this line we had
constructive interference imaged
as a bright spot.
And we recognize that in this
case the difference in the
distance traveled by the two
waves was 0 lambda.
And given that pattern,
we then concluded that there
was a general condition for
constructive interference.
That is if you had maximum
constructive interference,
the general condition that had
to apply was this:
that the difference in the
distance traveled by the two
waves was an integral multiple
of the wavelength,
where this integer N could be
0, or 1, or 2,
or 3, or 4.
And it's actually symmetric
here along the center of the two
slits.
So you would see the same kind
of interference pattern up here.
And so we call this
interference feature right here,
we often call it the zero-order
interference feature.
We call this one,
when N is equal to 1,
the first-order.
We call this one the
second-order interference
feature.
And in between the very bright
spots on that screen,
what we have are dark spots
here, here and here.
And what I am going to ask you
to do in recitation section,
actually next Tuesday,
is to look at what condition
has to apply in order to have
these dark spots which result
from destructive interference.
And, of course,
when you analyze that you're
going to see,
say right here,
the crest, the maximum of one
wave at the same point in space
as the minimum of the other
wave.
And you get maximum destructive
interference everywhere along
that line.
And what you will do in
recitation next week is actually
to figure out what the condition
is for destructive interference.
And that is going to be N plus
one half times lambda.
So, it is this observation of
these interference phenomena
that are characteristics of the
wave-like nature of anything.
In this case,
the wave-like nature of light,
of radiation.
On Friday, what we are going to
do is we're going to see this
same sort of interference
phenomena, a property of waves,
be observed from particles,
from electrons.
This diagram,
you are going to see once again
on Friday.
And we will use that to
demonstrate the wave-like nature
of particles,
electrons.
That is our evidence for the
wave-like nature of light.
Now, what we are going to do is
we're going to talk about the
other behavior of light,
and that is the particle light
behavior of radiation.
And I forgot to get out my
notes.
What is that evidence?
Well, soon after Thompson's
discovery of the electron,
there were some observations
being made of something called
the photoelectric effect.
And this was very curious.
The photoelectric effect is
simply that you have some metal
here and you shine some light on
that metal.
And what happens is that an
electron is ejected.
Metal.
Light coming in.
Electron comes out.
But the frequency of this light
that is coming in,
this frequency nu,
we talked about frequency the
other day, has to be greater
than or equal to some threshold
frequency, some threshold
frequency that I am going to
call nu nought.
In other words,
if I come in with radiation
here that has got a frequency
that is less than nu nought,
well, then no electrons come
off of the metal.
Maybe we could raise the screen
here for the moment.
Well, another way to kind of
plot that observation is to just
plot number of electrons versus
the frequency of the radiation.
And so if you're at low
frequency, there are going to be
no electrons that come off,
but then when you get to some
frequency nu nought,
all of a sudden electrons are
going to come off.
And the number of electrons
that come off is going to remain
constant as you increase the
frequency of the light.
And typically this frequency of
the light that causes these
electrons to be emitted is in
the ultraviolet range.
Well, this was a curious
observation in the late 1800s,
very early 1900s.
And scientists just started to
measure everything about these
electrons they possibly could
measure, because they just
didn't understand the effect.
And one of the things that they
measured is the kinetic energy
of the electrons.
Here I am going to plot kinetic
energy, KE.
And they measure the kinetic
energy of the electrons as the
function of the frequency of the
light.
Again, at low frequencies there
is no kinetic energy,
because there are no electrons.
But then here,
at some frequency nu nought,
all of a sudden electrons come
out, and lo and behold-- And
these are points just
representing the individual
measurements--
Lo and behold,
as you increase the frequency
above nu nought,
the kinetic energy increased.
It increased and looked
directly proportional.
The kinetic energy looked
directly proportional to the
frequency of the light.
Well, let me tell you,
that was a big mystery as far
as classical physical ideas were
concerned.
That was a big mystery.
Because, in the classical
physics that was understood at
that time, the kinetic energy of
the electrons,
KE as a function of the
frequency of light,
well, that classical physics
would predict that that kinetic
energy were independent of the
frequency of the light.
There was nothing in the known
classical physics,
classical electromagnetism that
would allow the frequency of the
light to be related in any way
to the kinetic energy of the
electrons kicked off.
There was no reason for why
bluer light, which has a higher
frequency, would eject electrons
and redder light,
which has a lower frequency
would not eject the electron.
And classical physics also
predicted that the kinetic
energy of the electrons should
be dependent on the intensity,
I am going to call it I,
the intensity of the light.
In kind of general this sort of
dependence.
That is, the brighter the
light, the more kinetic energy
these electrons ought to be
kicked out with.
In other words,
the brighter the light,
the more energy you were
putting into that metal.
And, therefore,
the electrons should be kicked
out with more energy.
That's what classical physics
was predicting.
But the measurements,
go in the lab and you do the
measurement, the measurements
showed that the kinetic energy
was independent of these
intensities of light.
This is the experiment.
It had nothing to do with the
intensity of the light.
The kinetic energy remained the
same no matter how bright that
light was, not matter how much
energy you were sticking into
the system.
Now what changed,
here, as you put more and more
energy or as you put more and
more intensity,
what changed was the number of
electrons that came off,
but not their kinetic energy.
So, this was another conundrum
here, in terms of being able to
explain it with the known
classical physics at that time.
These data were around for a
few years before Einstein took a
look at it.
And he looked at these plots of
the kinetic energy versus the
frequency of the light.
He looked at it,
for, say, this is the data for
metal B.
Here is the data for metal A.
In all cases,
it kind of looked like it was
linearly dependent on it.
And the only thing that was
seemingly different,
for the different metals,
was the threshold frequency
here.
What Einstein did,
a real leap here of intuition,
was that he went and he fit a
straight line to this data.
Well, he did a better job
fitting a straight line than I
did.
He fit a straight line here.
Y equals mx plus b,
no problem,
where kinetic energy is y and x
is nu, right?
He looked at that and
calculated the slope.
And he looked at it and he
looked at it.
And he goes finally,
very interesting,
because what was so interesting
here was the value of the slope,
the value of m.
The value of this slope here
was equal to 6.626x10^-34 joule
seconds.
No matter what metal he looked
at, the value of the slope was
6.626x10^-34 joule seconds.
So what, you say?
Well, it was very interesting
to Einstein, because just a few
years before there was a
gentleman who was analyzing
what's called black-body
radiation data.
Let me just explain this a
little bit to you,
but you're not responsible for
it.
What is a black-body?
Well, let's just,
for a simple example,
think about the burner on your
electric stove.
We will consider that to be a
black-body.
What you know is that when you
turn up the voltage,
that the temperature starts
going up, and at some point the
temperature gets high enough
such that the burner glows a
little bit dull red.
And then if you turn it up some
more, it gets hotter,
the burner glows a little bit
redder.
That's the black-body
radiation.
If you turn it up some more,
the burner glows orange.
Frequency going up.
If you turn it up some more,
and you better not do this,
the burner starts glowing
yellow.
And then, if you could,
and you probably cannot turn it
up some more,
it ultimately is white.
All frequencies.
Now what scientists had been
doing, is that they had been
analyzing the intensity of that
radiation from a black-body as a
function of the frequency.
And they did it for lots of
different temperatures.
This is our black-body
radiation.
I am plotting the intensity
here.
And so they dispersed the
radiation, they analyzed it as a
function of frequency,
and what they saw was a curve
that looked kind of like this.
And this temperature here,
we will call it T1,
that was for some temperature
T1, a low temperature.
This isn't in your notes,
because you're not responsible
for this.
I'm just trying to make the
importance here of this slope,
or I'm just trying to
illustrate the importance of
this value for the slope in the
photoelectric experiment.
And then at a higher
temperature here,
T2, the intensity got bigger,
but also the maximum shifted to
higher frequency.
And at temperature T3,
here now T3 is greater than T2
and greater than T1,
frequency shifts even to a
higher frequency.
That was the observation.
This is dull red,
red, orange,
etc.
Well, Planck was trying to,
along with a lot of other
people, understand those curves.
And he came up with a model.
And the model said that
materials, these black-bodies,
had oscillators in them.
And these oscillators were
emitting radiation.
These oscillators were
responsible for giving off this
radiation.
And he also added another twist
to those oscillators in that
those oscillators were
quantized, that they could only
emit discrete packets of energy.
And using that basic idea and
something called statistical
mechanics, he was able to
calculate the shapes of these
curves.
A lot of his calculation.
And so this green here is going
to be a calculated curve here
for T equals 1,
a calculated curve here for T
equals 2, a calculated curve
here for T equal 3.
He got the shape right,
but he didn't get the magnitude
right.
And he said how do I get the
magnitude right?
Well, what he realized is that
in that formulation,
what he had to do was multiply
the frequency of the oscillators
by this constant m or this
constant that is called h,
Planck's constant.
Where does Planck's constant
come from?
From this.
Hey, that's it.
It is, in a sense,
a fitting constant.
There isn't any derivation of
Planck's constant.
You cannot sit down and derive
It is our observation of the
way nature works.
So that is where Planck's
constant comes from.
And so you can imagine
Einstein's surprise when he
analyzed these photoelectron
data.
And, lo and behold,
out from the data comes the
same constant that Planck had
found.
And Einstein realized that
there must be something really
very fundamental about this h,
about what is now known as
Planck's constant.
So, he pursued.
And what he did then was he
just wrote down the equations
here for that straight line.
That's kinetic energy is equal
to nu, that is my x,
the slope is h,
and he found that the intercept
here was minus h times
nu nought.
So, this will be then plus the
intercept, or minus h,
times nu nought.
That was the equation of the
line he fitted through the data.
Now, he also realized he had
energy units on this side,
so he better have had energy
units on this side.
If this is a frequency,
then h must have the unit such
that h times nu,
this has to be energy.
And since this is the frequency
of the light coming in,
this energy E,
that must be the energy of the
incident light.
And here is where this equation
E equals h nu comes from.
This is it.
This is where this equation
comes from.
What it is telling you is that
the energy of the light is
proportional to the frequency.
This was the first time that
there was any indication that
the energy of the light had
anything to do with the
frequency of the light.
The very first time.
And what E equals h nu ended up
being thought of is as a
particle of energy,
as a packet of energy,
as a quantum of energy,
as, eventually,
it is going to be called a
photon.
The photon, this particle or
packet of energy,
is given by its frequency times
this constant,
this natural constant h,
Planck's constant.
You could have here any
frequency of light you wanted,
but the energy of that light
only comes in chunks given by
this quantization constant h
times that frequency.
I will explain that a little
more in just a moment.
Well, likewise,
this h times nu nought here,
that better be an energy,
also.
And so what that h times nu
nought is,
is the threshold energy.
Since nu nought was a threshold
frequency, h times nu nought
better be the threshold energy.
And let's try to understand
that in terms of an energy level
diagram.
I am going to plot here energy.
This electron that is bound to
the metal, before we shine any
light on it, I am going to let
its energy level be represented
here by this line.
This is the electron bound to
the metal way down here.
And what we know now is that it
takes some energy,
h times nu nought,
to rip that electron apart,
to pull it off.
And so I am going to draw
another energy level up here
which is going to represent the
energy of the electron free from
the metal.
So, I will call it "electron
free." And the amount of energy
that we have to put in to get it
out is this threshold energy,
h times nu nought.
This energy,
here, is like an ionization
potential, which you are
familiar with.
The energy required to pull an
electron off an atom or a
molecule is the ionization
potential.
Well, this is like an
ionization potential.
It really is the ionization
potential, except since it's
coming off of a metal,
historically we call it
something else.
It's called the work function.
And we give it often the symbol
phi.
But phi and h times nu nought,
they are the same thing,
the energy required to rip the
electron off.
And so what we
know is that the packet of
energy that you send in here has
to be at least this amount.
In other words,
if you come in with a photon
and the photon has this much
energy, E sub i = h nought,
you can ripe the electron off,
but you have to have at least
this.
Now, you can come in with a
photon that has more energy than
that, E sub i,
from here to here.
But if you do,
then the rest of this energy
here, the rest of this energy
goes to the kinetic energy of
the electron.
So, if you come in with exactly
the energy, the electron is
ripped off, but it doesn't move
away from the metal.
If you come in with a little
bit more, the electron is ripped
off the metal,
but it actually moves away then
from the metal.
And so, in this case and in all
cases, we have got to conserve
energy.
The incident energy of the
light, from here to here,
has to be equal to h nu nought
plus the kinetic energy,
or if I turn this around,
the kinetic energy is equal to
the incident energy minus h nu
nought.
This is an important
expression.
You need to know it.
I won't give it to you on an
exam.
You don't have to memorize it,
though.
You just have to reason.
You have to reason here,
conservation of energy.
You can draw this diagram and
figure it out.
Now, another very important
point here that I am going to
emphasize is that you
absolutely, positively,
no question,
have to have a photon of at
least this energy to get the
electron off.
What you cannot do is you
cannot have, for example,
a photon with half of this
energy, one half h nu nought.
Or, what you cannot do is have
two photons come in with a half
of this energy and make that
electron come off.
You have to have one photon to
make this electron come off,
and it has to have the
frequency nu nought.
That's the particle-like nature
of the radiation.
Even though you have the same
total amount of energy here,
the fact that you cannot have
two to pull the electron off,
you have to have one and it has
to have at least this quantum,
at least that packet of energy.
That's very important.
All the problems you are going
to do, if one photon comes in,
you're going to get one
electron off as long as that
photon has h times nu nought of
energy.
Now what we've got to do is we
have to do our own.
Yes?
If the energy of the incident
photon, if this energy here is
twice the work function energy,
yes, the electron will come
off, and the excess energy that
doesn't go to the metal to pull
the electron off goes to the
kinetic energy of the electron.
And so if this incident energy
is twice the work function,
well, then the kinetic energy
of that electron will be equal
to the work function.
I'm sorry?
Two electrons won't come out.
That's a good question.
What she asked was,
if I put twice the amount of
energy here with one photon,
will I get two electrons out?
No, absolutely not.
That is the quantum nature or
the particle nature of the
radiation.
Let's do our own photoelectron
experiment.
Question?
Those graphs up here,
kinetic energy versus the
frequency of light,
those were the predictions from
classical physics.
Kinetic energy independent of
frequency.
Kinetic energy increasing with
the intensity of light.
Those are predictions from
classical physics.
How I got them,
how I knew about them is
something that we're not going
to talk about because it's
wrong.
It's best at this point not to
go through the logic of how I
got that, but maybe after you
have 8.02 it will become obvious
to you.
Good question.
Let's do our own photoelectron
experiment.
Now we need the camera here.
And now, what I also need,
is-- Let me get this started
here.
What I also need are two
volunteers to help us do this
experiment.
Come on down.
Somebody else want to come?
Okay, come on down.
All right.
I have two volunteers here.
Oh, I forgot to tell you that I
need to do something,
so you've got to stay up here
for a moment.
I forgot to explain something.
My fault.
Sorry.
Maybe you want to turn around.
I forgot to tell you something,
here.
What we're going to do --
-- is use this device here.
This is an aluminum plate.
And you are going to see it,
here, on the side walls.
That is a picture of the device
we've got up here.
This is an aluminum plate.
And that aluminum plate is
mounted to a metal rod.
That's that blue rod.
And then there is a needle here
in that blue rod,
and it's mounted on a pivot,
so it moves very easily.
What we're going to do,
is we're going to put some
excess charge on this metal
plate.
And when we do that,
that needle is going to
deflect.
It's going to deflect because
those excess charges,
the electrons,
are going to run down that
metal rod and then onto the
needle.
And since these electrons repel
each other, and this is a very
low friction pivot,
this needle is going to move.
And then what we're going to
try to do is we're going to try
to do the photoelectron
experiment.
We are going to come in and
shine some UV radiation on this
plate and see if we can eject
electrons.
That's what we're going to do.
Now I've got my volunteers who
are going to do this.
Who wants to be the charger?
Who wants to be the discharger?
You'll be the charger,
okay.
This will be your weapon.
You hold that.
Keep your fingers on the yellow
plastic.
This is going to be your
weapon, the UV light.
I am going to need you in a
moment, so just stand by.
What is your name?
Don, okay.
Don, what you need to do is you
need to take that Lucite rod and
rub it really hard on the fur.
And what that is going to do
is, the fur has some natural
oil, and he is going to transfer
a little bit of the natural oil
onto that rod.
And there are some stray
electrons around and some
negative ions around,
and they like to be on that
oil.
But then we're going to contact
that rod with the aluminum plate
and the electrons will go onto
the aluminum plate.
So, you've got to rub this
really hard, and then you've got
to go and touch that and put the
electrons on.
And you should watch the needle
move here.
You've got to touch it on the
edge, actually.
Good.
Well, you charged it a little
bit.
That's not bad.
Now take the rod again and rub
it really, really hard.
[LAUGHTER] Really hard.
Touch the edge of the plate
there.
Touch the edge of the plate.
[LAUGHTER]
This way.
You've got it.
Pretty charge there.
Touch the edge of the plate.
Fantastic.
Now we need the discharger.
You've got to come right here
and shine the UV light on the
base of it.
You've got to get a little
closer.
Maybe turn your hand this way
so that people can see it
discharge.
Fantastic.
Try it again.
Come on, charge it up.
[LAUGHTER] Really hard.
Touch the edge of the plate.
[LAUGHTER]
This way.
This works the best.
All right.
Touch the edge of the plate.
Let's get it.
Fantastic.
Maybe just a little bit more.
We can get more electrons.
Hard, hard, hard,
really hard.
Okay.
Charge it up.
Oh, okay.
Discharge here.
[LAUGHTER] Fantastic.
What you saw was when the UV
radiation then was incident on
that aluminum plate,
the electrons were emitted,
and then the needle deflected
back.
Now we've got to do this one
more time.
Why don't you come over here?
What is your name?
Jenny.
Come on over here,
if you can.
And this time,
after you charge it up,
I am going to hold this glass
Pyrex plate between the light
and the aluminum plate.
And that is going to prevent
the UV radiation from going
through, and so it shouldn't
discharge.
Okay?
All right.
Go ahead.
Let's charge it up one more
time.
You really do have to rub that
oil on there.
[LAUGHTER] Really hard.
Touch it up here.
Fantastic.
Now I am going to put the light
there and now we are going to
shine it.
Oops, it's already discharging.
You've got to do it one more
time.
You've got to do the control
experiment here.
Really hard.
It's a little bit humid out
today, so it's a little bit
harder to make this work.
A little bit harder.
Done.
Get it up there.
All right.
Touch the side there.
Good.
That's pretty good.
Fantastic.
We've blocked the UV radiation.
Electrons didn't jump off.
Hey, this works.
Thank you very much.
Let's give them a hand.
[APPLAUSE] Thank you very much.
This photoelectron business,
it's really real.
What I want to do now is I want
to just work a couple of
problems.
And here is the first problem.
What it says is,
how many photons,
at the radiation wavelength of
1 picometer, do you need to
supply a pulse of energy that is
a 1 joule pulse,
say, from a laser?
It's a pulse laser.
Suppose you want to supply 1
joule of energy in this light
pulse.
That is what the problem says,
1 joule in a pulse.
Now, how do you work a problem?
Lots of ways to work a problem.
Sometimes I like to draw
pictures.
1 joule, that's my 1 joule.
I want 1 joule of energy.
But I am told that I have
radiation that has a wavelength
of 1 picometer.
That's 1x10^-12 meters.
That's the wavelength of my
radiation.
And I am asked,
how many photons do I need?
Well, what do you know about a
photon?
We said that the energy of a
photon is equal to h times nu .
That's one photon,
the energy of a photon.
The units here are joules.
Implied is joules per photon.
And so I know the wavelength,
I don't know the frequency
here, but I know the
relationship between wavelength
and frequency.
Frequency is equal to c over
the wavelength.
And so I can then calculate the
energy, and when I do that,
it's 1.99x10^-13 joules per
photon.
Carrying one more digit than is
significant because this is an
intermediate step in our
calculation.
And now, if I want a pulse of
energy that is one joule,
and each photon has 10^-13
joules per photon,
well, that's 1 J / 1.99x10^-13
joules per photon.
Well, you can calculate that.
It comes out to be 5x10^12
photons.
That's what I will need then.
That's the answer,
then.
Let me just write that down.
Let's work one more where we
can understand.
This is important,
because you need it for your
homework.
Here is the problem.
You've got power of a radiation
from a continuous laser.
You turn on your laser,
you've got power.
What is power?
Power is energy per unit time.
We're going to use in our unit
system the unit of power as
watt.
A watt is a joule per second.
It is how much energy is
delivered per unit time.
And we're told that we've got
radiation of 3 milliwatts,
that's 3.0x10^-3 joules
per second.
The question is,
how long will it take for a
total energy of 1 joule to be
supplied?
Well, 1 joule divided by
3.0x10^-3 joules per second
equals 330 seconds.
And then,
rushing through this,
one more.
How many photons at a radiation
wavelength of 1 picometer again
--
How many photons per second
have to be delivered if the
power of the radiation is 3
milliwatts?
Power is 3.0x10^-3 joules per
second.
The radiation is 1 picometer,
but we already calculated how
many joules there are in
radiation per photon with
wavelengths of 1 picometer.
That's 1.99x10^-13 joules per
photon.
Joules cancel.
And that means we're going to
have to have 1.5x10^-10 photons
per second, because each photon
has this much energy.
This was the power,
the rate at which we're
delivering the energy.
We're going to have this many
photons per second coming out if
the photons have that wavelength
of 1 picometer.
Great.
See you later this afternoon or
on Friday.